Sich selber anzusehen -
und ich glaube,
das geht vielen auch so,
wenn man sich auf dem Tonband hört
oder eben am Bildschirm
oder auf einer Foto -
sich selber zu sehen und mit seinen
Unzulänglichkeiten umzugehen.
Das ist nicht ganz einfach.
Daran habe ich mich nie gewöhnt.
Aber es ist dann irgendwann einfach
mal zu einer Normalität geworden.
Lampenfieber -
ist das noch ein Thema?
Leider ja! Ein furchtbares Thema.
Ich hatte immer die Hoffnung,
das nehme irgendwann ab.
Aber auch nach bald 40 Jahren ist es
immer noch schlimmer geworden.
Das hängt vielleicht
auch damit zusammen,
dass ich bei jeder Sendung andere
Leute nicht enttäuschen möchte.
Das spüre ich jeweils
mit Nervenflattern.
Kurt Aeschbacher!
Am nächsten Sonntag moderiert Kurt
Aeschbacher seine letzte Sendung.
Was treibt einen Menschen an,
bis 70 vor der Kamera zu stehen?
Und wie geht es weiter mit Aeschbi,
wenn das Rotlicht in den Studios
für ihn ausgegangen ist?
Davon handelt dieser Film.
Jetzt bin ich grad so am Studieren -
bin ich gerne
vor der Kamera gestanden?
Um das zu machen,
was mich interessiert -
in die Seele von anderen zu blicken
und da ich kein Psychiater bin -
ist eine Fernsehsendung
das ideale Mittel dazu.
Da gehören halt Kameras
als integraler Bestandteil der
Übermittlung von Information dazu.
Aber es ist nicht Tatsache,
dass ich, wenn irgendwo
an einem Fussgängerstreifen
das rote Licht leuchtet,
schon reinlächle,
weil ich auf Rotlicht
programmiert bin.
Sondern das ist einfach das Mittel
zum Zweck, um das zu übertragen,
was dann letztendlich
der Inhalt ist.
Als Mitglied des legendären
"Karussell"-Teams
stand Kurt Aeschbacher 1982
zum ersten Mal vor der Kamera.
Guten Abend, lieber Zuschauer
am Fernseher und hier im Studio.
Wir haben heute mit dem Kochen
etwas Besonderes vor.
Sie wissen, seit längerer Zeit
ist Kochen im "Karussell"
eine Tradition.
Das wäre es schon
fast gewesen für heute Abend.
Allerdings schleicht sich
nun langsam der Nebel ein
von unseren musikalischen Gästen.
Es ist eine Gruppe aus Holland.
Die erste Sendung
war eine Katastrophe.
Ich mache einen grossräumigen Bogen
um diesen Moment,
denn ich habe nur Fehler gemacht und
habe mich auch schrecklich gefunden.
Aber da kommt jetzt
wieder dieser Teamgedanke:
Meine Kollegen haben nicht gesagt:
"Das war ja ein Mist!"
Oder: "Du warst so schlecht!"
Sondern sie haben gesagt:
"Es hat noch Luft nach oben."
"Aber du hast etwas,
und du kannst an dir arbeiten."
"Und du hast auch
eine gewisse Ausstrahlung."
Und nur dank dieser Ermunterung ...
Das ist doch so schön,
am Arbeitsplatz Leute zu haben,
die einen ermuntern
und über die Fehler hinwegsehen,
weil sie finden,
die kann man
irgendwann einmal eliminieren.
Über diese Ermunterung
danach einen Weg zu finden,
den man ohne das
nie hätte machen können.
1987 startete Kurt Aeschbacher
mit seiner Sendung "Grell-Pastell",
die fortan für Gesprächsstoff,
Wirbel und Beschwerden sorgte.
Bin ich denn eigentlich tatsächlich
der ge-bodybuildete, geschniegelte,
mit nach hinten gekämmter Fönfrisur,
Unterhaltungsfuzzi Kurt Aeschbacher?
Im Zeitalter der Coming-outs muss
man Wahrheiten auf den Tisch legen,
oder man legt sie
Ihnen auf die Knie.
Und hört auf zu lügen,
sondern zeigt sich so wie man ist.
Herzlich Dank für die Aufbewahrung.
Mir war es wichtig, in einer Unter-
haltungssendung über Sachen zu reden
und die Leute auch mit Bildern
zu konfrontieren,
die im ersten Moment
vielleicht lustig sind,
im zweiten schluckt man leer,
beim dritten fängt man an zu denken.
Das war immer meine Überzeugung.
Unterhaltung ist nicht nur
oberflächliches sich Amüsieren.
Ich glaube einfach, ein Medium
wie das Fernsehen hat die Aufgabe,
nicht sensationelle Berichte
zu machen,
nicht Schlagzeilen zu produzieren,
sondern die Leute an der Hand nehmen
und sie zu Problemen hinzuführen
und vielleicht
nicht schon die Lösungen zu zeigen,
sondern einfach nur sagen: Denk mal!
Ich mache noch einmal den Übergang.
Ja, mach doch noch
einmal die Überleitung!
Seit 18 Jahren
moderiert Kurt Aeschbacher
seine Sendung "Aeschbacher"
in der Zürcher Labor-Bar.
Zu Gast ist heute u.a.
ein homosexueller Schiedsrichter.
Aeschbacher und sein Team
beherbergen Menschen,
die zum Nachdenken und Handeln
anregen sollen.
Kann ich noch etwas näher?
Das ist ja das Wunderbare
an diesem Beruf,
dass ich die letzten 40 Jahre
in einem konstanten Prozess
des Lernens gewesen bin,
vom Lernen für mich selber,
aber auch im Umgang mit Problemen.
Das gehört schon dazu.
Vielleicht betrifft mich
nicht jede Geschichte persönlich,
aber ganz viele Sachen
konnte ich natürlich auch für mich
anwenden und umsetzen.
Mit anderen Worten:
Ich bin eigentlich seit 40 Jahren
in einer Psychotherapie
und werde dafür noch bezahlt.
Vielleicht ist es auch an der Zeit,
dass man auch im Fussball
bald so leben kann wie man möchte,
ohne Geheimnis.
Goal ist ja schliesslich Goal,
wer auch immer es geschossen hat.
Es gibt ja kein halbes Goal,
das sog. schwule Goal.
Die "Tagesschau" ist nun bereit.
Einfühlsam, anständig,
frei von Zynismus -
das sind die Attribute, welche
die Fans ihrem Aeschbi zuschreiben.
Ich finde Zynismus
etwas sehr Negatives.
Zynismus schützt einen davor, auch
mit sich selber kritisch umzugehen
und man projiziert dann
alles gegen aussen.
Und ich finde, gerade so ein Beruf
verlangt viel persönliche
Verantwortung und verlangt auch,
dass man das,
was man macht, auch lebt
und nicht nur mit dem grossen Finger
auf andere zeigt.
sondern auch mit dem Finger
auf sich zeigt
und sich auch
immer wieder kritisch hinterfragt.
Aeschbacher moderiert seine Sendungen
ohne Netz und ohne doppelten Boden:
Kein Draht zur Regie,
keine Moderationskärtchen,
kein Teleprompter.
Nur so sei ein intensives Gespräch
mit dem Gegenüber möglich, findet er.
Sie dürfen sich
ein Herzchen aussuchen.
Freut mich. Hallo!
Massimo.
- Und?  - Alain.
Sind Sie auch zufrieden mit ihm?
Als ich vor irgendwie 100 Jahren
mein Coming out hatte,
war das ganz massgeblich wichtig.
Ich bekomme heute noch Mails
von jungen Leuten, die sagen,
dank mir habe ihre Mutter,
weil sie mich möge,
auch Verständnis gehabt.
Aber es geht nur im Öffentlichen,
nicht im Versteckten.
Sie führen die Leute gut.
- Bitte?
Ja, das versuche ich.
Das ist eigentlich meine Aufgabe.
Ich bin noch ganz in dem Modus, in
der Freude, diesen Beruf zu machen.
Wie es mir dann geht,
wenn die letzte Sendung über den
Sender ist, das weiss ich nicht.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
ich habe mich gut vorbereitet.
Aber es ist wie ein Gespräch,
das ich mit dem Dalai Lama
mal geführt habe.
Er glaubt ja an Wiedergeburt
und ist selber eine Wiedergeburt.
Ich habe ihn gefragt, wie er sich
seinen eigenen Tod vorstellt.
Da sagte er:
"Ich habe das ein Leben lang geübt,
aber ob ich es dann kann,
weiss ich nicht.
Ob ich das dann kann
mit dem Aufhören zu arbeiten,
das kann ich nicht voraussagen.
Packen Sie gerade jetzt
Ihre Vergangenheit aus?
Es ist wie eine Wunderkiste
entdecken, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Viele dieser Bilder,
die wir hier ausstellen,
habe ich jahrelang nicht mehr ge-
sehen, diese fast zehn Jahre nicht.
Seit über 50 Jahren ist
Kurt Aeschbacher auch Kunstsammler.
Es ist September: "Glanz & Gloria"
berichtet über seine Ausstellung.
Können wir es noch
ein bisschen kürzer machen? - Hm.
Zu meinem Geburtstag schenke ich mir
eine Ausstellung mit all den Dingen,
welche ich die letzten 50 Jahre
selber gesammelt habe ...
Du musst zu mir schauen,
nicht in die Kamera! - Ach so.
Ich bin natürlich so fixiert,
dass ich in die Kamera schaue.
Moderatoren?
- Ja.
Die sind rotlichtgeil.
Diese Ausstellung, die ich mir
zum 70. Geburtstag schenke,
ist ein Blick zurück in mein Leben.
Seit 50 Jahren sammle ich Kunst.
Sie hat mich immer fasziniert.
Es sind sehr viele Bilder
zusammengekommen.
Hier in der Ausstellung
sind es ca. 170 Bilder,
die ich für mich und für eine grosse
Stiftung gesammelt habe.
Was mich immer interessiert hat,
ist freche Kunst.
Wie dieses Bild
von einer englischen Künstlerin,
das einen berühmten Filmstar
mit Marmelade im Gesicht zeigt.
Jetzt hätte ich rausgehen müssen,
nicht wahr?
Vielleicht noch etwas kürzer.
- Kürzer? Machen wir kürzer.
Aber bei diesem
können wir schon etwas verweilen?
Ja so, dass ich zum nächsten Bild
mitschwenken kann.
Okay, gut.
Was ich zulassen möchte,
ist ein Blick in meine Seele.
In diesem Sinne ist es auch für mich
eine Offenbarung,
wenn man wieder merkt,
was man alles in diesem Leben ...
Jetzt war ich wieder zu lang, gell?
Wie schwierig ist es für dich,
wenn du die Regie abgeben musst
und nicht dein eigener Herr
und Meister bist vor der Kamera?
Ich habe jeweils Ideen,
wie man etwas machen könnte
und machen sollte
und was wichtig wäre
von der Aussage her,
aber so nach dem dritten Anlauf
kann ich mich dann jeweils
auch nach den Wünschen
der anderen richten.
Das ist eines seiner ganz wichtigen
Fotos aus den frühen Jahren.
Er zerstört einen alten Topf,
eine wunderbare Urne zerstört.
Muss man alles Alte zerstören,
damit das Neue Platz hat?
Und so bring mir Kunstwerke
sehr viele Inspirationen,
wie man die Welt
auch anders sehen könnte.
Der Beitrag für das People-Magazin
ist abgedreht.
Von den Kultur- und
Feuilletonredaktionen
erhielt Aeschbacher nicht einmal
eine Antwort auf seine Einladung.
Ich denke, es hat einen Zusammenhang
mit der Tatsache,
dass man bei vielen Menschen
in einer Schublade landet.
Ich als Unterhaltungsfuzzi bin
in dieser Unterhaltungsschublade.
So einem traut man
vielleicht nicht zu,
dass er sich auch ernsthaft
mit Kunst befassen kann,
dass er ernsthaft interessiert
ist an Musik.
Das ist das einzige,
über das ich staune,
ist, dass man nicht
mehr Neugier hat,
dass einen der Teufel zwickt
und man sagt:
"Jetzt nimmt es mich
trotzdem wunder,
was denn da dahinter steckt."
Unterhaltungsfuzzi
ist so despektierlich.
Warum setzt man sich selber
so herunter?
Vielleicht ist es ein Schutz.
Ein Schutz vor Angriff.
Ich kann mich
nicht anders definieren.
Ich kann sagen:
Ich war ein Leben lang,
die letzten 40 Jahre, Journalist,
per Zufall im Bereich Unterhaltung.
Ich musste mich aber in diesem Sinne
immer als Unterhalter
titulieren lassen.
Darum mache ich
grad den Sprung nach vorne
und nehme diesen Begriff
gleich voraus.
Seine Freunde und Fans
kamen in Scharen
und liessen sich von Kurt Aeschbacher
durch seine Ausstellung führen.
Aus der Zeitung erfuhren sie,
dass Aeschbis Sammlung
Millionen wert sei.
Du bist ein reicher Mann.
- Glaub das nicht!
Logischerweise wird in der Schweiz
am Schluss alles heruntergebrochen:
Was verdienst du?
Wie viel Geld hast du auf dem Konto?
Diese Sammlung
ist nicht Millionen wert.
Ich habe immer sehr früh
gewisse Künstler gekauft,
die heute
vielleicht etwas wertvoller sind,
die ich heute
auch nicht mehr kaufen kann,
weil sie viel zu teuer
geworden sind.
Es war nie ein Investitionsgut,
die Kunst,
neben Aktien oder Häusern
oder was auch immer.
Sondern es war ein Verzicht
auf ganz viel anderes,
wo aber der Wert der Sammlung
eigentlich völlig nebensächlich ist.
Kurt Aeschbacher
ist Betriebswirtschafter.
Er war auch immer Unternehmer
und wird es weiterhin sein.
Im Moment als Besitzer
eines Fitnessstudios
und als Herausgeber
einer Zeitschrift.
Fernsehmachen
hat ja ein gewisses Suchtpotential
und aufgrund dieser Freude,
diese Arbeit zu machen,
lässt man sich manchmal
auch ein wenig korrumpieren.
Ich habe mir immer gesagt,
es läuft sich besser auf zwei oder
auf drei Beinen als nur auf einem.
Wenn es hier nicht mehr läuft,
lahmt man dann gehörig.
Das Unternehmertum
hat einen grossen Vorteil:
Man arbeitet mit Risiko,
man setzt sein eigenes Geld ein,
das man dann auch verliert,
nicht wie gewisse Manager,
die fremdes Geld verlieren
oder verlochen.
Ich finde, man kann monatelang
über Sachen nachdenken,
was und wie man sie
machen sollte und könnte,
aber als Unternehmer muss man
irgendwann einmal einfach machen.
Und machen heisst,
vielleicht Fehler machen,
im besten Fall erfolgreich sein.
Aber überprüfen,
ob das, was man im Kopf hat,
auf dem Markt auch funktioniert.
Und so habe ich
zig unterschiedliche Geschäfte
mehr oder weniger erfolgreich
versucht zu lancieren.
Jedes Jahr moderiert Kurt Aeschbacher
die Modeschau
des Luzerner Labels LU-Couture
im Kultur- und Kongresszentrum.
Heute feiert Aeschbi
seinen 70. Geburtstag.
Es war sein letzter freier Abend
im Oktober.
Vielen Dank.
So eine adrette
Geburtstagsgratulation
habe ich also bis jetzt
noch nie bekommen.
Wie fühlt es sich an - 70?
Nicht anders
als 69 und 364 Tagen.
Die Zahl macht gar keinen Eindruck?
Nein! Offenbar macht es
allen anderen grossen Eindruck.
Alter hat ja nichts mit Krankheit
oder mit der reduzierten
körperlichen Möglichkeiten zu tun.
Es ist ein Tag, der für mich
keine besondere Bedeutung hat.
Nicht weil ich mich scheue,
sondern weil es für mich
ein Tag wie jeder andere ist.
Aeschbacher ist auch
ausserhalb der Fernsehstudios
ein gefragter Moderator.
Durch den heutigen Abend führt er für
eine grosszügige Spesenentschädigung.
Die Arbeit der jungen Schneiderinnen
liege ihm am Herzen.
Die Übergänge müssen schneller sein.
Ich kämpfe dafür.
Ich springe dann immer gleich raus.
Die privaten Auftritte und saftigen
Honorare vieler Fernsehmoderatoren
geben auch immer wieder
Anlass zu Kritik.
Es ist ja eine Arbeit,
und zwar eine Arbeit,
die sehr viel Vorbereitung braucht.
Viel Engagement, in der man sich
immer sehr exponiert.
Es ist ja völlig normal, dass eine
solche Arbeit bezahlt werden muss,
genau so, wie der Coiffeur nicht nur
Freude hat am Haare machen,
sondern eben auch
eine kreative Leistung erbringt.
Die soll entschädigt werden.
Ich bin nicht der Meinung,
dass man das nur bekommt,
weil man beim Fernsehen arbeitet.
Aber du hast deine Bekanntheit durch
die Arbeit vor den Fernsehkameras!
Ohne Zweifel, ein gewisser
Bekanntheitsgrad ist gegeben.
Das gilt für eine Bachelorette,
die sich irgendjemanden
an den Hals wirft
oder die Hosen runterlässt
genauso wie für jemand anders.
Ob das dann nachhaltig ist
und ob es 40 oder 50 Jahre funktio-
niert? Dann ist Leistung gefragt!
Und vielleicht
muss man diese Leistung
dann auch im täglichen Alltag
beweisen
und kann sich nicht nur
darauf beziehen, dass man
man einen gewissen Bekanntheits-
grad in den Medien bekommen hat.
Das finde ich
einen grossen Unterschied.
* Klatschen *
Herzlich willkommen
zum heutigen Abend.
* Dynamische Popmusik *
* Jubel und Klatschen *
* Sie spielt "Happy Birthday. *
(Mehrere)
# Happy Birthday to you.
# Happy Birthday lieber Kurt.
Ruhe sucht Kurt Aeschbacher immer
wieder in seinem Chalet in Davos.
Doch Stille
findet er auch hier nicht.
Ein Tinnitus
ist sein ständiger Begleiter.
Ich bin froh,
dass wir zwei Bäche haben,
die neben dem Haus runterfliessen,
das gibt so ein Grundgeräusch,
weil es in meinem Kopf
nie völlige Stille gibt.
Es ist immer
eine Art Pfeifen oder Rauschen.
Wenn gar nichts mehr passiert,
werde ich plötzlich aufmerksam,
dass das so ist.
Aber ich habe gelernt,
mit diesem Pfiff in meinem Kopf
Frieden zu schliessen.
Ich sage: "Ah, du bist hier."
Der Bach,
der so ein Grundrauschen gibt,
hilft mir mich abzulenken
von dem Herrn,
der sich in meinem Kopf breit macht.
Aeschbi
schützt sein Privat- und Gefühlsleben
stets freundlich, aber konsequent.
Jedes Wort vor der Kamera
scheint mir mit Bedacht gewählt.
So kommt denn auch die Antwort
auf meine Frage,
was denn die Absetzung seiner Sendung
mit ihm gemacht habe,
professionell daher.
Im ersten Moment
hat es mich traurig gemacht.
Im zweiten gibt es Sachen,
die man einfach annehmen muss.
Und es ist gleichzeitig
eine wunderbare Chance,
darüber nachzudenken:
Wo stehe ich? Wohin will ich?
Zu verschnaufen und zu sehen,
was auf mich zukommt.
Und auch schauen,
worauf ich Lust habe,
was auch immer das sein wird.
Ich habe nie Sachen verschoben,
im Sinne von -
das mache ich dann später,
wenn ich pensioniert bin,
wenn ich keine
geregelte Arbeit mehr habe.
Ich habe immer versucht, was ich
wichtig fand, möglichst zu machen,
soweit es nicht nur ein Traum war,
sondern auch ein Projekt.
Ich habe nichts Aufgeschobenes.